من اسطنبول ينضم الينا مراسيا صباح
العربيه زيدان زينجل وزيدان يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك سنه سعيده عليك كيف احتفلت
اسطنبول براس السنه الميلاديه
صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير نادين وصباح
الخير للجميع مشاهدي قناه العربيه وصباح
العربيه كل عام وانتم بالف خير وسنه خير
ان شاء الله وسعاده وفرح بعيدا عن كل
المناقيسات وبعيدا عن الاوبئه والصراعات
صباح الخير صباح سنه جميله وان شاء الله
مليئه بالحب والسعاده طبعا اول شيء سهام
ونادين سلامات كثير من عشرات الاشخاص اللي
التقيناهم عشرات العرب الموجودين في
اسطنبول يوم امس اثناء اجراء مقابلات
سلامات كثير لصباح العربيه من الجاليه
العربيه هنا في اسطنبول همم طبعا همم
احتفالي احتفاليه خاصه كانت يوم امس في
اسطنبول للمره الاولى او للمره الثانيه
همم الاحتفالات بدون الوفاء لكن هذه المره
بدون اي اجراءات وقائيه والتباعد
الاجتماعي غير موجود لذلك الاحتفالات كانت
صاخبه هنا في اسطنبول تحديدا في ميدان همم
تقسيم وشرع الاستقلال في نيشان وايضا في
كاليكو في الجانب الاسيوي هنا العشرات
بللالاف وصلوا الى مضيق البوسفور حيث
نتواجد الان مع الاسف الضباب غطه قليلا من
المشهد في الخلفيه التي همم وراءنا او في
المشهد الذي خلفنا مضيق البوسفور مغطى في
صباح اليوم الاول من هذا العام بالضباب
لكن همم هذا الدواء لم يمنع الالافنا
الوصول الى همم مضيق البوسفور والاستمتاع
بمشهد الالعاب الناريه واحتفل هنا في
بدايه العام الجديد الاجواء في تركيا عاده
في هذه المناسبه هي اجواء عائليه بامتياز
الكل يتجهز يتجهز الى هذه المناسبه همم
قبل عده ايام التحضيرات الالاف زين الشرف
همم الشرفاء الشرفات المنازل همم هنا ايضا
الشوارع اكتست بالاضاءه الجميله
شجر شجره الميلاد في كل مكان الاجواء كانت
مميزه هذا العام
طبعا اعود الى موضوع الاتراك وكيف يحتفلون
في هذه المناسبه كما ذكرت الاجواء عائليه
بامتياز الجامعي يجتمع هنا في البيت مع
طبق الديك الرومي المفضل لدى الاتراك في
ليله راس السنه ايضا العائله تجتمع
الرسائل يتم تبادلها بين الجميع لكن طبعا
الجيل الجديد بعض الجيل الجديد يفضل
الاحتفال في بعض المطاعم يوم امس هنا في
مضيق البوسفور كانت السفن او الاحتفالات
داخل السفن السفن همم انطلقت فيها تمام
حوالي الساعه 9:00 مساء مع الالاف الذين
همم خرجوا في او ذهبوا في السكون في جوله
سياحيه واحتفلوا بدايه راس السنه هنا في
مضيق البوسفور بالعموم نتحدث انها كانت
ليله جميله جدا همم الامنيات بان تكون
العام المقبل العام جميل هناك عشرات
الفعاليات التي ستستضيفها مدينه اسطنبول
وايضا تركيا في عموم همم في خلال هذا
العام نتحدث هنا عشاق الرياضه نهائي دوري
ابطال اوروبا سيكون هنا في اسطنبول شكرا